floodwaters swept through streams rivers
and neighborhoods from San Diego to San
Francisco with as much as 35 cmet of
rain predicted for some areas the slow
moving storm system termed an
atmospheric River by meteorologists also
lashed the state with wind gusts around
kmph the Los Angeles River normally a
nearly dry concrete channel was
transformed into a torrent close to
overflowing its banks
in San Jose the fire department rescued
three people and several dogs trapped by
the rising Guadalupe River we launched
our boats got them in got them out of
the water and uh successfully got them
to shore in Sacramento large trees
toppled causing power outages and
hundreds of thousands of people are
without electricity in Central and
Northern California in the San Francisco
Bay Area roadways flooded and residents
piled up sandbags in San Diego entire
neighborhoods were flooded and some
people were forced to climb up on their
roofs for safety police and fire
department as well as Mayors urged
people to stay home and stay
safe but as always some treated the
emergency as a lark including one person
who rode a surfboard down a flooded Rock
strewn Canyon in Los Angeles and Ventura
counties mudslides damaged homes and
blocked highways leading to mandatory
evacuations while in the Sierra Nevada
mountains heavy snow could create white
out conditions making travel hazardous
altogether 38 million people are under
flood watch the storm is expected to
last for another day or more Rob
grenolds Al jazer Los
Angeles make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer